>> Laura: WE ALL KNOW JEB BUSH
WAS TROUNCED IN THE PRIMARIES
AND IN HIS OWN STATE BUT STILL
CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHY DONALD
TRUMP WON OR WHO'S LEADING THE
PARTY.
HE RESURFACED IN A "USA
TO COMPARE AND CONTRAST
WE'REONED BY FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTE
WE'REONED BY FOX NEWS CONTRIBU E
CONTRIBUTOR RAMONA ARROYO.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHO'S THE HEAD OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
HE DOESN'T REPRESENT -- I DON'T
THINK HE'S A TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVE.
>> Laura: WAS HE CONFUSED BY THE
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE GOT
THE NICKNAME "LOW ENERGY."
>> HERE'S MY FIRST QUESTION, WHY
ARE THEY EVEN TALKING TO JEB
BUSH?
IS CARLY FIORINA GOING TO MAKE
AN APPEARANCE.
HE'S A LOVELY
HE'S A LOVELY M
HE'S A LOVELY MAN
HE'S A LOVELY MAN A
HE'S A LOVELY MAN AND
HE'S A LOVELY MAN AND -
HE'S A LOVELY MAN AND --
>> Laura: HE'S MEAN TO TRUMP ALL
THE TIME.
>> LOOK AT THE OPTICS.
HE'S SITTING IN A MIDDLE SCHOOL
LIBRARY ON A CHILD'S CHAIR AND
BEING INTERVIEWED BY THE
PRINCIPLE.
>> Laura: SO COMPARE AND
CONTRAST THAT WITH FOLKS, DONALD
TRUMP TODAY.
>> I THINK WE'RE DOING A VERY
SPECIAL JOB AND I REALLY BELIEVE
IT WAS TIME TO DO THAT JOB
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THE UNITED
STATES WOULD HAVE DONE WELL IF
IT WENT THROUGH FOUR OR EIGHT
MORE YEARS OF REGULATION AND
REALLY A VERY ANTI-BUSINESS
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
IN ONE YEAR WE'VE CUT MORE
RESOLUTIONS IN MY ADMINISTRATION
THAN ANY OTHER ADMINISTRATION IN
FOUR, EIGHT OR 16 YEARS AND WE
>> YOU SEE HIM DOMINATING.
THE FEW DAYS AT DAVOS HE
DOMINATED.
>> Laura: HE WAS SUBDUED BUT I
LIKE IT.
>> SOBER AND IN COMMAND OF THE
MATERIAL.
>> Laura: RAMON, YOU'RE
COMPARING POOR JEB BUSH IN A
MIDDLE SCHOOL LIBRARY TO DONALD
TRUMP WITH THE WORLD'S BILLION
AIRS.
HERE'S JEB BUSH ON TRUMP'S
RHETORIC.
>> I DON'T THINK HE'LL SUCCEED
IF HE CONTINUES ON THE PATH.
I DON'T SEE A GOOD OUTCOME WITH
THAT ULTIMATELY WILL DRAG DOWN
THE POSITIVE THINGS HE AND HIS
TEAM ARE DOING.
HE WON THE PARTY.
>> HE WENT ON TO SAY TRUMP NEEDS
>> JEB BUSH AT THIS POINT IS
LIKE ELTON JOHN AND CHER, THEY
KEEP ANNOUNCING RETIREMENT BUT
WON'T GO AWAY.
GRIPPING PRIMARY CANDIDATES THAT
ALSO LOST.
>> Laura: NO ONE WILL CALL YOU
LOW-ENERGY RAMON.
I'M NEVER DOING AN INTERVIEW IN